[Music]
did you guys hear about Brian Ortega and
slapping jay Park Oh
see ya who's Brian Ortega yeah it sounds
like you're talking about your friends
and I'm like I don't I didn't go to that
party recently there was a fight and in
that fight there were these guys that
were attending this fight and during
this fight is when one guy named Brian
who was supposed to fight the other guy
so scary name not very scary namely hi
I'm Brian who can take you out you're
supposed to fight Korean Zombie all
right what the [ __ ] is going on right
inverses Koreans on no but it's not
Brian he's Brian the Ryan okay so ready
feels like something Robert uh okay so
both of them they're supposed to fight
but then Brian got an injury like he was
corseted it so Jay Park the rapper
signed Korean Zombie okay so he's like
he's managing him and so what is a
fighter is it yeah the fighter I'm sorry
okay sign ours jay-z that's what jay-z
did to these sounds a lot of fighters
fighters basketball please in general
that makes sense because the love of my
life Michael B Jordan signed
professional gamers so I get it does
Michael B know that you're the love of
his life
oh yeah he will that's literally my Gaza
I can literally pull his number right
now my phone Michael B Jordan yeah
anyway yes okay can we just send him a
photo of Gina you know G's gonna flash
him his her T's right now if you're cool
with that you cannot do that to me
because yeah you're gonna break her
Salah I just follow this outside oh we
were so ready for it I had hope because
I said you gotta stay in a lahar to a
lot of people bail out of the lights and
listen maybe they get wavering filling
my eye I see the light through to the
Barry it was thing called right in front
of me it really was it really was and my
racist ass was like oh yeah maybe he
does know Michael
I don't know any better I I held on to
it I was me I was in me as a non racist
I was like that's not the same kind of
black oh my god especially it's a non
racist the other emphasized side zombie
was about to happen because Brian got
injured and he couldn't do the fight
with what with the Korean zombie then
that's when he started talking [ __ ] hey
baby what's up he started talking [ __ ]
about Brian saying he ducked the fight
okay okay yeah and then that's when you
read this fight and then Brian walks up
the moment Korean zombie goes to the
bathroom just you know coincidentally
that's when Brian walks up in flaps jay
Park of the manager the manager who is
not even he's a civilian
that's his [ __ ] made [ __ ] yes with open
hand yeah but it's also like satisfying
money you know what but I gave her a
check I get it
I found weird then people always say
like he open hands slapped him where if
you close hands slap somebody that's
technically a punch yeah true like do
you remember that slap in the subway in
New York the woman slapped the soul out
of her bond with that giant guy yeah I
love that
it's cup but it's still a slap for sure
yeah okay here let me show you some
faces this is Jay Park
he's pretty oh my god he's pretty come
on don't be a J part you got some more
pictures of his ass too
this is Korean Zombie that you know if
you're a zombie
that means you died before me back
that's how bad yeah well he's Undead
he's under and then this is brain Ortega
okay now go back to dr. J McMahon with
those those braids they are trouble
McMahon got the smallest nipples yeah
okay now I'm gonna be playing a video
clip okay two partners first one is
we're Korean zombies talking [ __ ] and
the second part is we're like you here
you see you paint
here that the actual slap and then you
see the aftermath of the Oh is he gonna
slap my baby that I just started dating
Jay Park absolutely I'm all about it so
he said uh you know it doesn't matter
Holloway volcan Tosca Ortega
but Ortega already ducked at one time so
he doesn't you know he doesn't need a
fighter fighter this duck in him already
a zombie had this out of this is great
stuff this is some good trash talk area
I didn't know we added a mini
we should haven't seen the slap spine
once too you know I want to see it
there's something about a man slapping
you that's so
disrespect wait what did Jake say again
I couldn't hear much Jay was saying that
Brian Ortega ducked the or dodged dodged
the fight like you're dodging it like
being a little [ __ ] pretty much instead
of the fact that he got injured and
that's the reason you couldn't get he
couldn't fight I see um listen I'm with
you guys but I'm just trying to reports
now you're killing it tough you're
absolutely [ __ ] know you're murdering
you're you're slapping the [ __ ] out of
this story did this story is in a
[ __ ] dark alley and you're kicking
the [ __ ] out of it flawless victory and
you just introduced Bo's to her new man
why don't you go ahead and put his face
back on the screen and flip that laptop
on around for me just so I got a good
there you go right there right there for
you either just for you Oh
browse town a while out I mean I know
I'm not paying since eyebrows this fine
bring your fine ass on over here I think
he has a bunch of shirtless photos on
his Instagram great and I'll be there
today a huge controversy not huge
country it's just a lot of gossip
they're just like oMG I can't believe he
did that
especially for Korean Zombie he's like
what a little [ __ ] man like I'm the
fighter come to me but J talk [ __ ] yeah
sure but but he had a slapping on a
punch yeah so he got slapped because it
was disrespectful to it would be both of
them were being disrespected but I mean
also do you match disrespect with
disrespect I don't think so I tried you
I if I let you over in front of me and
you don't like mess my speed like I will
get over in the middle lane and I will
never let you bet over yeah you'll be
halfway to [ __ ] Boston if I let you
in and you don't wave Oh followed you
home I'm gonna kill you
I'm gonna kill you lonely at the bear
and the very least I'm going to let all
the air out of your tires you got to do
more than one because they got a spare
so you got to do at least two cuz you
weren't polite that's all thanks when
you move over for a motorcycle and they
go and they don't wait they don't wave a
human I get it though like what
motorcycles Oh like like for them to do
that they gotta take one hand off cos
don't do it but guess what move the [ __ ]
over so yeah you should yeah but you
also have bumpers I was slightly
inconvenienced serious question about
cyclist I don't know if anyone here can
answer from you or somebody in the
comments how do motorcyclists use Apple
Macs they just have to know how they
hear it they can do that too but they
also they have the holster on their
handlebars this is like an industrial
one that's [ __ ] memorization what
that's what taxi drivers doing London
they you have to go to school to like oh
my god yes it's so many like cuz like
they just got GPS like London has so
many like back streets not just that
like how many did yes I see a fairly new
technology but they literally have to go
to like I think it's like two to four
years of school to learn all the streets
and let okay but how good is a few more
years to the for you how good does it
feel when of motorcycles waves so cool
cuz there's such cool people or when you
let a semi-truck in and they flash all
their lights and [ __ ] oh you like that
and they do it so cool so cool what I
was like - why'd you grow up too fast I
was a kid yeah see oh yeah there's a
Thomas guides in your car cuz he the
Thomas guides okay we didn't know we
didn't have map court we didn't have
MapQuest yeah we didn't have rich enough
to have Tom's house that Thomas guy's
there it's a book of maps in a certain
area and you had to like map it out Oh
oh I remember my mom had a zip-up binder
when she kept in her Thomas guide I
driver had one but I never really saw a
party as the partition we met we were in
the lobby well maybe you saw it the time
that you [ __ ] hit them with it a
glove just left like two marks I need it
you are here sticker otherwise I'll just
freak out like you're gonna give me the
top spot please give me the you are here
to make it small we're at the mall -
like I need it like they need to know
that you are here people were low IQ
people and we needed to be bigger where
the [ __ ] is your here that's right now
at the malls have you seen those new
info thingies where you like it's touch
screen and it tells you exactly where
you are and then you tell I'm like oh I
want to go to Sephora and it's like that
it pour - and then it gives you
directions
hey by the way are me all glad that we
have all is touch screen now that we
have coronavirus like how [ __ ] stupid
is our society man we set it up to fail
I come on it you know give it a good
lick before you just like oh it's great
they have a touchscreen and so easy they
need to make voice commands less
annoying do they actually use it we're
just done an airplane and [ __ ]
everything's touchscreen guess what you
have corner you're [ __ ] dude I [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ] because the touchscreen
like there's always someone behind you
it's like and your whole future it's
chill yeah I'm like how hard this is
nothing much you don't have to press the
heart I hate that people like still pull
your seat to get up when they have
[ __ ] farmers right here how hard is
it to do this
I just it makes me so upset like who
like just common sense at some point oh
maybe this is distracting to the person
who's actually in the sea now watch this
lady do it like she was going through
the owl or gone yeah going through the
highway to get to a window seat and
every seat she just pull it off and I
just looked at her cuz she was like get
out right now just looked at her she
looked at me I was like you disgust
nobody here's the thing if you do that
[ __ ] all the way to the bathroom and
then I see you upright getting in the
bathroom like this oh you better be
[ __ ] disabled
you better [ __ ] as soon as you reach
the bathroom door you better hit the
ground as our army caller and then you
got to reach up pull the slide and crawl
in
because otherwise you're an [ __ ] I
think the worst flight I've ever been on
was a it was a flight to Japan but I was
in a Chinese airline ah and it was like
it was all like mainland Chinese people
I've never wanted to hijack and crash up
an airplane so I would so you're not
only how like they turn up I don't go
[ __ ] this you don't think turn off the
light so you can sleep so like
everyone's dead asleep and this [ __ ]
lady behind me just goes and everyone
just woke up and turned my I looked at
her and she didn't give a [ __ ] or a care
in the world and I've never wanted to
punch someone so bad in my life the
worst flight I was definitely on was
just like a commercial flight because
typically we fly private
the fact that you just have to stand in
line and
and go through like like security I was
like oh my god people really have to
take this suit off cuz I get we have
this likely heard stories about him yeah
I had never I was like oh my god this is
how people really travel they scratched
up you Louie Vuitton luggage oh my god
it was so many people on this plane like
well I'm not used to flying more than
like seven people yeah you're like well
there's like 100 200 people right I mean
I mean like maybe like 13 with like the
shift don't bore chef yeah yeah yeah
it's so weird I was just oh my god this
is a real thing you guys are talented we
started talking about UFC and we got
here oh [ __ ] that's right Marvel place
the people that know don't know a [ __ ]
about UFC huh I told you guys I warned
you but hey you wanted us to talk about
it what is the UFC have to do with
private planes I would say this jay Park
have a private plane I bet you he does
[Music]